en los últimos vídeos todos estos que
hemos hecho acerca del efecto doppler
asumimos que la velocidad con la que se
desplazaba la fuente o sea este puntito
que estaba emitiendo la onda es
estrictamente menor que la velocidad con
la que la onda misma se propaga y bueno
lo que vamos a hacer en este vídeo es
tirar esa hipótesis a la basura y vamos
a considerar el caso en el que la
velocidad con la que el puntito se mueve
es exactamente igual a la velocidad con
la que la onda se propaga bueno al menos
vamos a ver qué pasa cuando esto sucede
en las fórmulas que tenemos para la
frecuencia y el periodo y después vamos
a tratar de entender qué es lo que está
pasando en el fondo entonces regresemos
a donde estaban nuestras fórmulas lo
cual es justo aquí
a ver ahora lo que queremos hacer es
asumir que la velocidad de la fuente es
exactamente igual a la velocidad con la
que lado no se propaga vamos a asumir
esto entonces en este dibujo este
puntito tendría que estar justo aquí
a ver entonces en esta fórmula que es lo
que pasa cuando la velocidad de la
fuente es igual a la velocidad con la
que se propaga la onda pues aquí lo que
tenemos es un cero
si tomamos en cuenta que la velocidad de
la fuente es igual a la velocidad con la
que se propaga la onda en esta fórmula
la fórmula para obtener el período
observado por este observador que se
encuentra en medio de las vías del tren
con el tren corriendo hacia él pues aquí
tenemos dos cantidades que son
exactamente la misma y se están restando
entonces si restamos una cantidad menos
algo que es igual a esa cantidad lo que
nos queda es un cero que lo
multiplicamos por lo que lo
multiplicamos va a seguir siendo cero
entonces el período observado por este
observador va a ser exactamente igual a
cero esta persona de aquí tiene que
esperar 0 segundos entre una cresta y la
otra o sea todas las que éstas llegan
exactamente en el mismo momento y qué
pasa con la frecuencia pues la
frecuencia en esta fórmula tiene aquí en
el denominador cero o sea que la
frecuencia observada es 1 entre 0 que
también podemos haber obtenido esto
diciendo que la frecuencia era 1
periodo y esto que es pues esto es
simplemente algo indefinido ahora cómo
lidiamos con estas cosas indefinidas
pues lo que hacemos es aproximar las
poco a poco na entonces como lo vamos a
ver es qué pasa cuando la velocidad de
la fuente sigue siendo más chica que la
velocidad con la que se propaga la onda
pero cada vez se acerca más la velocidad
de la onda pues este número nos va a
seguir quedando positivo pero además
entre más se acerque la velocidad de la
fuente de la velocidad de la onda más
grande se va a ser este número porque
vamos a estar dividiendo entre algo cada
vez más chico cada vez más parecido a
cero y entonces la frecuencia observada
se aproxima el infinito cuando la
velocidad de la fuente se aproxima a la
velocidad de la onda y bueno estas ondas
no necesariamente tienen que ser ondas
de sonido
más adelante vamos a profundizar en eso
de las zonas del sonido y vamos a hacer
vídeos especializados en eso pero todo
esto que hemos dicho aplica para
cualquier hombre
ahora todo esto tiene sentido
o sea recordemos cómo es esta onda del
efecto doppler tenemos a la fuente que
está emitiendo la onda por aquí y está
justo en este segundo emitiendo una onda
de color azul pero ahora tenemos donde
se encontraba la fuente hace exactamente
un periodo cuando se emitió la cresta
pasada nuestra fuente estaba digamos por
acá y entonces esa cresta de la onda se
debe de encontrar en estos momentos más
o menos por acá y entonces lo que
hacemos es regresar nos otro periodo en
el tiempo o sea cuando la fuente nuestro
puntito estaba por acá y cuando la
fuente estaba por acá emitió otro pulso
y ese otro pulso actualmente tiene que
haberse propagado hacia todos lados
radialmente hacia afuera hasta como por
acá si nos regresamos otro periodo de
tiempo para ver la cresta anterior
nuestro puntito verde de nuestra fuente
se encontraba a cero
1 2 3 periodos de tiempo en una posición
por aquí y justo en este segundo hace
tres periodos de tiempo emitió otro
pulso de la onda y lo emitió cuando
estaba que antes de trasladarse entonces
el centro de la circunferencia es este
punto y la onda se propagó radialmente
hacia todos lados impresos las ondas son
representadas por circulitos hasta
llegar como por acá entonces si tenemos
a nuestro observador por aquí
esta persona está observando un periodo
muchísimo más chico que el que
observaría cualquier otro observador por
acá o sea este periodo entre una cresta
de la onda y la siguiente es muchísimo
más grande que este periodo y bueno esta
es la razón de por qué sucede el efecto
doppler ahora si la velocidad de la
fuente es exactamente igual a la
velocidad con la que se propaga la onda
qué es lo que pasa pues en el instante
actual pues tal vez nuestro puntito que
es la fuente se encuentra por acá
está emitiendo un pulso de la onda y
entonces pensamos dónde se encontraba
nuestro puntito hace un periodo de
tiempo se encontraba como por acá y
entonces la cresta de la onda que emitió
nuestro puntito cuando se encontraba que
hace un periodo de tiempo hasta donde se
tiene que haber trasladado precisamente
como la onda se está propagando
exactamente a la misma velocidad que la
fuente entonces tienen que recorrer
exactamente la misma distancia en esta
misma distancia porque se están moviendo
a exactamente la misma velocidad
entonces nuestra onda tiene que estar
por acá y si nos regresamos otro período
de tiempo nuestro puntito tiene que
estar exactamente aquí y si nos fijamos
en donde está la onda en este segundo
pues la onda se tiene que encontrar
exactamente aquí justo por eso de que la
onda se traslada exactamente a la misma
velocidad que el puntito y entonces
recorren exactamente las mismas
distancias en el mismo tiempo y entonces
qué pasa con nuestro observador que se
encuentra aquí
lo que va a pasar con este observador es
que va a escuchar todas las crestas toda
la onda exactamente al mismo tiempo en
el que la fuente llegue a sus oídos y
bueno sigo hablando del sonido pero esto
se aplica a cualquier hombre el chiste
es que la onda llega al observador
exactamente al mismo tiempo que la
fuente emisora de la onda
ok mejor pongamos en nuestro observador
como por aquel para que este objeto
pueda pasar y éste puede escuchar todo
sin morir en el intento entonces qué es
lo que éste va a escuchar en caso de que
ésta fuera una onda de sonido no
necesariamente tiene que ser de sonido
pues en lugar de escuchar un sonido
agudo como lo haría éste porque aquí ya
no va a haber una frecuencia que ya no
va a haber una onda definida todo va a
pasar de un solo golpe lo que éste va a
escuchar es un solo traspaso
porque aunque la onda que este puntito
estuviera emitiendo se pudiera dibujar
así donde este tiempo es el periodo el
periodo con el que fue emitida la onda y
hayamos decidido dibujar esta cresta de
este puntito
este observador lo que escucha es toda
esta onda todo este ciclo aplastado y
ximo bueno de hecho mucho más aplastado
que esto porque todo esto tiene que
caber aquí este observador
ni siquiera escucha eso o sea a ese
observador lo que le pasa es que llegan
todo esto aplastado al mismo tiempo o
sea la onda está aquí y las tres crestas
de la onda van a estar exactamente en el
mismo punto entonces ni siquiera se
alcanza a escuchar un sonido muy agudo
se escuche a simplemente un solo
trastazo y cuando estamos hablando
particularmente de ondas de sonido es
justo a esto a lo que se refieren las
personas cuando hablan de la explosión
sónica qué es lo que sucede cuando la
fuente emisora de sonido se traslada a
velocidades cercanas a la velocidad del
sonido y entonces cualquier observador
que se encuentre cerca de la trayectoria
de ese objeto lo que escucha no es
ninguna frecuencia porque está toda
aplastada y sima y entonces llega toda
en un solo golpe
solo momento toda esta energía de sonido
llega de trancazo y bueno vamos a hablar
de eso en el próximo vídeo hablando de
los números de mar